et la nuit c'est combien dort pas et la
journée c'est une salle de classe
[Musique]
et on fait courir aussi ici donc la nuit
il dégage des tableaux et puis il dort
le matin ils font rentrer le tableau et
puis on commence les cours les délais
première pour même sont donnés
[Musique]
moi j'ai trouvé nécessaire de ne pas les
abandonner quand on les abandonne ce que
nous tous on a perdu voilà quand on perd
l'éducation ça veut dire que tout le
monde a perdu on a travaillé ensemble et
il y a la pluie de tout le monde et puis
voilà on a réussi à intolécent pour cent
au CP et 95% à l'entrée en 6e
[Musique]
il y a lieu donc au de renforcer donc
les infrastructures il y a donc lieu de
pouvoir assurer l'alimentation scolaire
afin que les enfants puissent être
maintenu donc à l'école et il y a aussi
besoin vraiment et de
les enfants et à surmonter donc les
chocs psychologiques
[Musique]